Vladimir Putin's announcement at the
weekend that he was increasing the alert
level of Russia's nuclear forces is
Raising fears that the war that Russia
has launched against Ukraine could turn
into something even more dangerous some
kind of nuclear conflict
well I've taken a few minutes out of the
TV studio here in Berlin at DW to speak
to one of the world's leading experts on
nuclear weapons his name is James Acton
he's based at the Carnegie endowment
think tank in Washington DC and he
writes and researches a lot about
nuclear weapons and how escalation can
happen between nuclear powers
so I asked him what exactly first of all
was it the Vladimir Putin has announced
please bear with us there's some banging
in the background
so Putin ordered the Russian defense
minister and the Russian Chief of Staff
to increase the alert level of Russia's
deterrent forces uh which include but is
not limited to Russia's nuclear forces
we don't know exactly what that's going
to entail in practice we wait to see uh
the there's been media reporting today
that the U.S government has not seen any
changes to Russia's nuclear force
posture yet
um we may not see any I hope we don't
see any but I am expecting to see some
changes over the next few days
essentially the process of moving those
forces closer to the point where they
could be used to convey some kind of
nuclear threat what is your most likely
interpretation of the signal he's trying
to achieve with this
I can offer you various interpretations
but I actually find this quite a
difficult threat to understand what
Putin is trying to do one possibility is
that he's trying to say to the US
stay out of this conflict do not
intervene directly which is a threat
that he actually made explicitly when he
announced his invasion to the Russian
people
another possibility is that he's trying
to make the US and its allies change
their behavior to back off to lift
sanctions to stop supplying uh new uh
sorry to stop supplying equipment and
material to Ukraine another possibility
is that this threat is targeted at
Ukraine itself he's trying to uh scare
them into backing down or uh increases
leverage at the negotiating table
um and given that uh Russian Ukrainian
negotiations uh now appear to be ongoing
um part of actually what concerns me
here is it's not clear precisely what
Putin hopes to achieve through this
threat what specifically he's thriving
and how should people understand like
the importance of this even in in any of
those interpretations how unusual is it
for a leader especially a leader of a
superpower to make it a threat like this
it's unusual but not entirely
unprecedented if you look back through
the history of U.S Russian and U.S
Soviet uh crises the last time that one
of those States alerted their nuclear
forces during a crisis was in October
1973 during the final stages of the Yom
Kippur War so you have to go back almost
50 years to find an occasion
um to find the most recent and kind of
roughly analogous occasion to this that
I think underscores how unusual this
kind of nuclear threat actually is
um and you know I don't think that Putin
is about to launch a nuclear attack
tomorrow but I do think that the danger
of nuclear war the likelihood of nuclear
war is rising and we could think about
this in terms of Rift which is the risk
is the pro is the product of probability
and consequence and while the the
probability of a nuclear war is still
fortunately quite small the car
consequences are so large that the rift
kit in my mind uh is high right now
we have put in this situation
making this threat the Western world is
looking at this and thinking well what
is the the best response at this stage
what is your advice to the US
Administration and leaders here in
Europe who are thinking about how to how
their messaging should be now after this
thread
right now my advice is twofold firstly
it is to stay the course in terms of
their military posture at the moment
there is no need whatsoever to increase
the alert level of American or British
or French nuclear forces what I would
try to do though is to give Putin an
off-ramp ultimately Ukraine has to
negotiate an end to this conflict if
it's to survive as a as a nation state
as as well as it's been doing on the
battlefield uh you know the
extraordinary performances of examed
forces I think ukrainians know that if
they want to avoid you know the leveling
of their cities is put into grozny in
1999 to 2000 they have to negotiate so I
think you know we should make it clear
which sanctions we're willing to lift
um uh if Russia and Ukraine can
negotiate a ceasefire I think that is
worth something that's conveying to the
Russians right now I think we can re-up
some of the security building measures
that the U.S to Nato put to Russia
um
uh in January so you know in short we
have to try to find a way so that Putin
can back out of this crisis in a way
that leaves Ukraine as an independent
state that's not easy to do we can't
make him take that pathway but we can at
least open the door in the hope that he
will walk through it
and
how did How likely do you think he is to
to pursue something like that I know
that you're not specifically a Russia
expert but given the fact that he has
brought this nuclear threat element into
this conflict how easy it is it to back
down from such high stakes to accepting
a solution which feels well below the
rather maximalist War aims with which he
went into this conflict
Putin is faced with a bunch of
unattractive options right now
right negotiating a ceasefire in a way
that preserves Ukraine as an independent
state is an unattractive option
fighting a prolonged war against Ukraine
that is a complete bloodbath and results
in the deaths of tens and tens of
thousands of Russian service members is
really unattractive using nuclear
weapons is really unattractive so in
order that Putin has good options here
some that he wants to pursue he's faced
with a bunch of lousy options and he has
to choose the least bad of those
um and that's why I think it's strongly
in our interests to make that negotiated
ceasefire the least bad of these
different options that Putin has to
choose right now you know Putin is a
position that many leaders find
themselves when they launch Wars that
prove a lot less successful than they
hoped they would be and at the end of
the day almost all wars end through a
negotiated process in which each side
has to make agonizing concessions that
it hates to make
my point is that we should try to speed
up that process
um so that you know we we make Putin as
likely as we can do there's a lot here
that's out of our control we want to
make it as likely as possible that Putin
takes this place saving way out of this
crisis as soon as possible uh in a way
that doesn't involve like the
destruction of Ukrainian cities or Worse
still the use of nuclear weapons
um so that would be the the kind of
positive trajectory
um where the West can try to nudge uh
Putin towards a a positive or A least
bad outcome
um what's the alternative where do you
see the risk of a chain of escalations
that lead to a nuclear use
there's various Pathways that you can
imagine but the one that honestly
worries me the most in this situation is
the pathway in which Putin's nuclear
threat on this occasion fail as I think
they will like I don't think they're
going to cause
Ukraine to back down or the US and its
allies to back down and Putin is left
fighting a bloodbath of a prolonged
conventional War
um in which the Russian economy is in
tatters Russian soldiers are being
killed left right and Center there is no
end in sight of this conflict in which
Putin perhaps starts to worry about
whether his his rule at home might be
threat like I don't know whether that's
likely or not but we know that so I
don't know whether it's likely that that
that there could be serious threat to
Putin's rule emerging but we know for
example that Putin has talked publicly
about his quote disgust unquote at uh
Gaddafi's kill uh and I think it's quite
likely that Putin worries about ending
up with the same fate so in that kind of
scenario the possibility that as a last
desperate role of the dice to try to
bring an end to this conflict Putin uses
nuclear weapons like I can't exclude
that possibility that's that's the thing
that worries me most
and what kind of use of nuclear weapons
would be we'd be looking at there is it
uh where he might use them in Ukraine
itself or that he might use them uh
outside Ukraine as some kind of warning
to to Western Powers what kind of
scenarios can you imagine mostly likely
in principle it could be either of those
it's very hard to predict what I would
say is we may learn more in the next few
days about Putin's thinking in this
regard
right now the U.S reports it's seen or
we've had media reports I should be more
careful we've had media reports that the
US has not seen any visible observable
changes to Russia's nuclear posture you
know it's possible that the alert order
was completely a bluff I think that's
unlikely and that Putin is bluffing
theory of international politics hasn't
done very well over the last few months
another possibility is that this was ex
you know Putin's order was
um uh related exclusively to Russian
command and control which is like the
least bad version of this
however we could see Russia alert its
strategic nuclear forces that's its
nuclear forces that can reach the United
States it might Place uh nuclear
warheads on bombers it might send more
submarines to Sea
um in all of those different cases there
Putin would be clearly leveling a threat
at the United States and if it
progressed to nuclear use in that
scenario one would expect Russia's
long-range nuclear weapons to be used
conversely you know Russia also has a
large variety of non-strategic Delivery
Systems that can't reach the United
States on a day-to-day basis those
Delivery Systems are not stored with
nuclear warheads if we saw Russia start
to move nuclear warheads from the
storage locations to the deployment
location of its non-strategic weapons
then Russia would likely be trying to
convey Earth nuclear threat to the
Ukraine and in that case if it ended up
in nuclear use then I think the target
would be Ukraine so I I think we will
know a bit more about possible scenarios
uh when and if Russia's nuclear positive
visibly changes in the next few days
like hopefully it won't but if it does
that will give us a bit more about I
think uh tell us a bit more about
Putin's thinking
um and where is the the deterrent effect
of the West's nuclear forces here
um because we're we're talking about
actions which would see Vladimir Putin
using nuclear weapons where nobody else
has used them and facing the potential
for a some kind of massive retaliation
perhaps also in a nuclear sense so
why is it why why these thoughts even
possible given the potential uh
retaliatory consequences well I mean
firstly Richard I point out that this
kind of nuclear use is not unprecedented
in fact it's the only precedented form
of nuclear use is nuclear used to try to
end a conventional War
um in a way to avoid a huge amount of
conventional fighting obviously the big
difference between the end of the second
world war in the Pacific and today is
Japan didn't have a nuclear armed Ally
in 1945 Ukraine the us is not a formal
Ally but it's a friend of Ukraine and I
you know I think the U.S nuclear forces
and French and British nuclear forces
will work heavily on Putin's psychic he
will be fully aware that the use of
nuclear weapons could lead to
retaliation that's why I think he's
unlikely to do it
um but I think the the rationale here is
that he will weigh up the consequences
of using them and the consequences of
not using them and if not use if the
consequences of not using them appear
really terrible
um you know the loss of some Dreadful
conventional war in a way that
threatened in Putin's mind grip on power
then I think you start to get in a
situation in which you may view the
risks of using them as being lower than
the risks of not using them
and you said that I mean maybe to close
here
um you said that there hasn't been
something
an alert of this nature since 1973
that's a long time ago
um how dangerous is this is this moment
is it also do you feel the most
dangerous moment uh in world affairs
since around that time
um I find it very hard to quantify the
level of danger that we now face I do
think at the very least this is the most
dangerous moment in a U.S Russia crisis
um since not only the end of the Cold
War but at least you know the last five
or may you know the last five or so
years of the Cold War
thanks to James Acton for taking the
time today and if you want to follow
more of our coverage of the crisis then
follow us on YouTube on Twitter on
Instagram and of course on our own
website dw.com